welcome to this video playing fun zinan
and let's see if it's is one of them
more sane games that is playing on one
of the crazy ones it looks like not sure
once in a while he's playing really
crazy stuff according to the name which
means out of your mind hmm oh so talking
to me underman okay I really didn't want
to play this ok we just pumps back to
him some sort of Kings Indian benoni
whatever ok let's take the pawn frankly
speaking most of those pseudo ankles are
completely incorrect just a pawn for
nothing this is one of them but we are
at splitz chest you still need to win
and so on but essentially why it is just
a poor novel for no particular
compensation
ok Knight b6 maybe not sure what's best
here I mean can also play Bishop at 40
but Knight b6 ok let's let's just take
that and let's see maybe 9 p-5 later
yeah the only slight compensation is
that ok the spawns a bit week before be
three is weak but it shouldn't be enough
to justify a pawn sacrifice Bishop age
six if possible also covering be too yep
this is this is a good idea maybe just
be three preventing Nazi fall and should
I play let's let's get rid of this
Bishop this is a good good piece and
they took change it should be alright
I also have some kinks I'd take ideas
based on the the King position like 94
to g5 back
f5 hmm
this I'm not sure I'd okay the night
isn't great on g3 anyway maybe I can
regroup it Knight d2 to see 492 to see
form
Luke see one that's 90 32 bit bit
annoying if I played this and not see
for Quincy for he's got some work on the
B file with the night um rupee for ideas
hmm not quite sure what to do let's hope
it's are ok anyway he plays rugby 6 i'm
intended to not be five
you can just take of course when I'd be
so I look b6 this was my idea all right
so what's to blame
hmm
and probably a me to get out of this and
now go in here need to cover the the
night look a to b 6i have a five
I cannot take d5 really just take and
Quincy for the deadly pen still if it
takes a plane I'd be five problem i'll
knock the one that's also not bad and
maybe rookie one
threatening to take and plain I'd be
five should be a good simplification
mmm not sure what you should do look b6
Mary
the night saying some cannot play Queen
takes and 95-94 shouldn't be bad I mean
it's a good knight on d4 controlling all
kinds of squares yep this should be you
should be fine
he was threatening threatening to made I
be here yeah Quinn's off please the
night end game is quite easy with to
protect the pawns yeah that's a check
this briefly he got some counter play
round here yeah this is some counter
play but probably him is plated somehow
maybe around here it's not so easy for
y2 to make any substantial progress
after this I think this is systems
placed the rook now and now white is
really better I'm I'm threatening to to
play exactly like in the game and he can
only the co come once to take and play
this just trying to hold on but this
more and more is just an extra phone so
at the end this this would count his
some he doesn't have enough pieces to to
make enough threats and pressure on the
pawns alright thanks for watching